the joy of travelling by train the
wide-open space hurtling across borders
arriving in new places with the promise
of new scenes and new encounters since
1972 the one month in terrell pass has
helped young Europeans under 26 access
at all but at a price from 245 euros for
a light schedule rising to almost double
that now an idea to give young Europeans
of free pass on their 18th birthday is
gathering steam reversed and when we are
took him to give more occasion you
including the oxen Yara Viet an internal
ticket shanking from the rotation only
own hours mr. Weber has asked the
Commission to launch a scheme in the
1980s it was being used by 250,000
people a year one estimate puts the cost
of free passes now at up to 1.5 billion
euros if two-thirds of today's five and
a half million young Europeans use it
Quran sets the hunter stretchy alle oxy
owning the new me enlighten the
nucleotide passion in upload appearance
of verizon on mobile design ETA
dimension does as achieving an ethnic
stand yar feel like the Sunnah concrete
now saw a deer with which tartan homes
other MEP saw potential ecological
advantage vented as novel pointless mom
of the Sheena is assumed Amitabha
gruesome on Danny season and he whom
kind problem the woman's developed as
the auto patient Airlines year this year
from toyota land Rises million oil
become palestine and webcam problem
anytime table no still waiting for a
green signal the idea hasn't even left
the platform yet but if it does
politicians hope it'll recapture the
imagination of increasingly
disillusioned young people and their
fondness for their diverse continent
my